I want to thank you all for coming to our session on targeted therapy
frontiers in microsatellite stable metastatic colorectal cancer.
I'm Paulo Hoff from University of Sao Paulo in Rio de Janeiro.
And with me today I have Dr. Scott Kopetz, who's Professor of
Medicine at University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer Center.
If I could have my
next one.
Yeah. So when we talk about colorectal cancer, it's
interesting to put a little bit in perspective how the field has evolved.
Originally, Dr.
Heideberger created 5-FU in the
1950s, and this drug has remained the backbone
of treatment for colorectal cancer since.
It was only in the late '90s and in the beginning of this century that we had the
addition of irinotecan and oxaliplatin.
And then with the combination treatment, our overall survival for
metastatic colorectal cancer, which used to be around one year,
started to approach two years. Then in
2003, we had the arrival of the first
targeted treatments, bevacizumab, the anti-VHF
monoclonal antibody,
had a significant improvement over the use of irinotecan with
5-FU, and subsequent to that, we had the arrival of the
anti-EGFR cetuximab. With cetuximab
and others anti-EGFR, we start having, for the first
time, biomarkers that we could use to select a patient
population, albeit a negative biomarker in this case.
So we are able to select those patients who will not respond to
anti-EGFR, although we're not still having
a definitive marker for those who will respond.
And now in the 2020s, we're starting to face a new area
of treatment for colorectal cancer.
Of course, perhaps the greatest success story that we had in
the last few years was the use of
immunotherapy for patients who have microsatellite
instability. Those patients have very
significant responses. In some cases, when, for example, we
use new adjuvant immunotherapy for patients with rectal
cancer, we have response rates approaching 100%,
with patients that previously had to be treated with radiation,
chemotherapy, and surgery being treated with immunotherapy alone.
However, we do know that those patients are relatively rare.
Only 15% of the colorectal cancer patients have
MSI, and we still have to decide how to treat those
patients who are MSS.
So now we're facing kind of a bridge between the time of the
chemotherapy and the relatively
wide targeted monoclonal antibodies to a more directed
therapy for those patients with MSS, trying to achieve with them
what we have achieved with patients with microsatellite
instability. So one point is that MSS is not
really resistant to immunotherapy, it's kind of invisible to immune system,
and perhaps that's one of the strategies that can be used.
Those tumors have low intrinsic immunogenicity.
They suffer from immune exclusion.
They have dominant suppressive signals, redundant signaling,
and of course, there is a therapeutic mismatch between what they have as
targets and what we have available.
So we have multiple targets that we can use now to try to
improve the results for patients with microsatellite stable
disease. The core drivers, RAS, RAF, HER2,
signaling pathways like c-Met and VEGF.
We can work on the microenvironment and scape with CCAM5
and T-Rex. We can also start to see
some improvements on the agents that we use for immunotherapy.
And of course, we know that there's limited benefit with monotherapy, but
perhaps with combinations, we can start to change this field.
And certainly emerging targets such as TGF-beta, DDR,
oncokinase inhibitors, et cetera.
It seems that in the future, we'll be using more combinations and looking for the
right therapeutic platform, and that's going to be key.
And there are several novel strategies that are being developed for the treatment
of metastatic colorectal cancer that are stable.
We have the targeted delivery with the ADCs.
Now with the bispecific antibodies that's starting to appear,
we can work on immune engagement with T-cell engagers,
active recruitment, antibody strategies against
different types of targets, small molecules, and of course,
we have now a next wave of treatments with rational combinations
and integration of immuno-oncology on the treatment of those patients.
So I don't think that MSS will be solved by a single
drug, but
it will be solved with strategy. And the meeting that we have today, the
presentations that we have today are focusing on those
strategies and targets. So to begin, I would
like to invite Dr. Scott Kopetz to give the presentation
focusing mostly on RAS and RAF.
Thank you, Paulo. Thanks so much. I'm really delighted to be here
with everyone the last day to
talk through these two areas. So this is a double header,
as it were. We'll be
breaking the presentation up into discussion about
BRAF followed by RAS in the second half.
So as mentioned, I'm a professor at GI Medical Oncology at MD
Anderson
and
have been working on this space.
So to start BRAF,
some disclosures.
SoThink about the distribution of actionable alterations in colorectal
cancer just to put things in framework.
We'll be focusing certainly on the RAS population,
40 to 50% of metastatic colorectal, including
the immediately targetable alterations of G12C,
as well as the BRAF mutation. We'll be focusing on the MSS
subset of BRAF, which accounts for about 8%.
So a little history as well,
maybe not going back as far as 5-FU, but sometimes it
feels like it, thinking about the first inhibitors of BRAF,
the mutant-selective inhibitor, Vemurafenib, that
really reiterated this difference, how colorectal
cancer is different, and I think this is a message that has continued to
resonate as targeted therapies have defined.
A key theme that we'll hear throughout the discussion of
KRAS and BRAF is this idea
that colorectal cancer has a very unique
feedback mechanism
that's really robust. It is certainly present in other contexts, but
in colorectal cancer,
a really nice, elegant, unbiased screen identified
EGFR as a synthetic lethal partner with BRAF
inhibition and identified this feedback
mechanism, and gives you really nice synergistic
preclinical data like you can see in that graph on the right.
It's worth, I think, just taking a step back because this is so fundamental,
colorectal cancer, and going through the cartoon of how we think about the
disease. So this is the context of a BRAF mutation that's present,
and with effective inhibition, you do get a transient
downregulation of signaling through the MAP kinase.
But there are these feedback mechanisms that are in place, and these get
de-repressed in a lot of the phosphatases and others
mechanisms, and there's not just one, but multiple, that can result in
upregulation of receptor tyrosine kinases, of which EGFR
is the predominant, albeit not only mechanism.
This EGFR then gets activated. This was not a
biologically relevant target otherwise.
Monotherapy EGFR inhibition in BRAF is not active.
But only in the presence of BRAF does that get activated, then signals
down and around through the
still inhibited mutated BRAF, then reactivates the
pathway. And then coming in with the combination of the EGFR and
BRAF then is sufficient to result in durable pathway
inhibition.
This same mechanisms with some slight differences applies with
KRAS, as we'll get back to later.
Fast-forwarding through a lot of
work to
define and explore this is the BEACON study, which is the
study that led to the FDA approval of BRAF targeted.
So this was a study of encorafenib and cetuximab versus the control
arm in second and third line.
And this resulted in an improvement in overall survival, hazard ratio of
0.6,
with now what we appreciate is a BRAF
EGFR pattern of toxicity, which is some
relatively mild acneiform dermatitis, some
arthralgias, anemias
that are present. So this then was approved in second and third
line colorectal cancer. But there's certainly a recognition
that we can do better, and
part of that is really understanding how the tumor is adapting.
One of the areas is understanding this concept of
key genomic alterations at progression, and here
looking at what's been acquired at the time
of progression on encorafenib and cetuximab.
You can see the blue are ones that are present before and after.
Red are ones that are then acquired at the time of progression.
And what you can appreciate is a fairly high prevalence of KRAS,
NRAS,
MAP2K1 mutations, as well as some MET amplifications that were present.
Now,
an interesting finding is that in colorectal cancer especially, maybe
more so than other tumor types, we see these alterations
co-occurring. And for example, encorafenib and cetuximab,
double it out of BEACON, had a number of patients that had
more than one alteration that were identified.
And
this is in the common pathways, as we've mentioned.
Now, it's intriguing when we went back and now looked and said, "Well, where are
these coming from?" One of the ways you can do that is look at the mutational
signature,
and we can identify that there's a kind of a new mutational process that
looks like it may be present. This is the
SBS17A and more prominently B. But
really, this looks like a signature, this adaptive mutability
that's present. And so this is indeed some things that we'll see at the time of
progression. And it turns out that we can identify those
patients that are more likely to acquire these
secondary mutations. Those that have really high
cell cycle signaling on transcriptomic
profiling at baseline are the ones that are much more likely to,
you can see with a really significant P value here, to have these secondary
mutations that develop. Now, the other key finding is
that not only are these multiple, but they're also highly
subclonal.
And the intriguing
observation here is that we can use these max VAFs, and this is a
ratio of the max VAF of the acquired alteration compared to
the total maximum level of the VAF in
ctDNA at the time of progression to estimate the
clonality. And it really suggests, with some back of the envelope
calculations admittedly, that you're looking at about one in 100 cells
inside the total tumor burden that actually have
these resistant mutations.So
there is a
growing sense that even though you may see these in patients at the
time of progressions, they may not always be the key driving alteration.
We'll come back to that.
One of the clinical observations that we see also pre-clinically, and this is some
work from Stefania Napolitano from my group,
looked at how do we actually treat the...
Can we do crossover studies first line and second line in mice?
And so what was identified is just like in patients, in
pre-clinical models, the efficacy of BRAF-targeted therapy is
actually reduced in models that have been previously treated with
chemotherapy and progressed. And so what you can see is
the purple and the green. The green is when the encorafenib
cetuximab is given as a first therapy, and then the purple is when
the
tumor has been treated and progressed on FOLFIRI.
And so it's an intriguing
finding that aligns with what we see in the patients that response rates tend to
align with different lines of therapy.
So one of the implications of this is that maybe serial therapy may not
be as effective, that there is some degree of cross resistance that occurs.
And then when we take three different models here that are resistant
to BRAF and EGFR and combine them with
chemotherapy, you can indeed see at least additivity
pre-clinically, if not a bit more.
And so this was some of the scientific rationale that
really underpinned
the BreakWater study, which is a first-line study now.
A three-arm
standard of care was a dealer's choice
of chemotherapy that could include a triplet cytotoxic
EC, and FOLFOX was the primary experimental arm,
and then there was an arm of just EC alone.
So the idea of no cytotoxic chemotherapy and just bringing targeted therapy in.
The overall response rate was 67% in this versus
37% with the standard of care. You can see the EC arm
falls somewhere in between, and there is increased durability of this.
When we look at ctDNA dynamics, this is now looking
at about six weeks on treatment, so
looking at the dynamics of what's happening with that BRAF V600E
clone in the ctDNA. And you can see in the control
arm that about 35% went from detectable to
undetectable in ctDNA, and that went up to
45% with the EC and then up to
67% with the EC and FOLFOX as an
immediate readout. And that was associated with better outcomes, as you can
imagine, of those that cleared versus those that didn't.
The PFS of first line was superior, hazard ratio
of 0.53, going from seven months to 12.8 months.
We've always known that BRAF is a poor prognostic
population that does not respond as well to first-line therapy,
so this is standard of care is aligned with our expectations,
and there's an improvement. But more importantly, the overall
survival was improved, and we got a doubling of overall survival from
15.1 months to 30.3 months, so a hazard ratio of
0.49.
And so this was what led to approval of first-line
BRAF
V600E in combination with FOLFOX.
Now, the EC arm, if you remember, there was a third arm that did not have
chemotherapy. I know it's
hubris not to have 5-FU
in first line, but there we go. We gave it a try.
And what we saw was it was really in between, and so this idea that
even EC alone without cytotoxic may be better than
the cytotoxic control arm.
Adverse events, very similar to what was seen before.
Some arthralgias, rash, tends to be not very
severe. You see it's only 1% grade three, four rash, which is
much less than you'd expect with an EGFR inhibitor.
So there's some interesting data about how BRAF may mitigate the
toxicity of EGFR inhibition. There's actually even a company out there
that is developing a topical BRAF inhibitor to treat
EGFR rash, so it's a fascinating
biology.
Now, one of the questions is, well, what if we gave
a FOLFOXIRI triplet cytotoxic therapy?
Is the chemo better than a really more intense
cytotoxic backbone? And indeed, what you can see is the
green is the FOLFOXIRI bevacizumab patients and
the outcomes were still superior with the EC and FOLFOX.
Now, for some patients who maybe had adjuvant therapy or just
by provider or patient choice would prefer to use FOLFIRI
backbone, so there was a second cohort that randomized patients
to FOLFIRI EC versus control. And in
very similar manner, their response rate was higher, 39% to
64%. And you can see the
OS at an interim result, and the final results will be
presented at ASCO for this. But based on this data in
the US at least, the labeled indication, the full approval
for encorafenib cetuximab in first line allowed either a
FOLFOX or a FOLFIRI backbone. So although we don't have full
results yet, the FDA was happy with the trends that we
were seeing.
So we did the same exercise then post-BRAF and identified
that the alterations between baseline and end of therapy
here and now is very similar to what we saw before.
And you can see the EC alone had a fair number of these secondary
alterations. We're also able to quantify the
exon deletions of BRAF as another
mechanismAnd that manuscript will be
coming out here shortly. But one of the intriguing
observations was that the EC in combination with
FOLFOX resulted in fewer patients with these acquired
alterations. So this
is looking at patients treated with EC, and here's the
proportion of patients with detectable ctDNA resistance mutations,
but when you look at the EC FOLFOX, that really is
substantially mitigated. So it's suggesting that perhaps at least
some of the
clinical benefit that we may be seeing with this is really constraining
some of the mechanisms of potential resistance, which I think at
a very simple level may make sense that an acquisition of a KRAS
mutation would get around the BRAF EGFR treatment, but
wouldn't result in resistance to the FOLFOX backbone.
And so the tumor
needs to identify mechanisms that may result in resistance to both
mechanisms. But there is at least a sense here that some of this
adaptive mutability may be blunted, and I think really an interesting
area to better understand how these tumors are adapting,
and how we administer the targeted therapies may differ.
Now, another area certainly trying to understand transcriptomically
how the tumors may differ in those that are
responsive and those that are resistant.
And there are some really interesting signals around
a interferon gamma response
in patients. So this is an epithelial signal
that's seen. So even though this is not an IO therapy, we can
see
when we look at a very simple cytolytic score, which is a kind of a validated
measure of granzyme perforin activation.
In the
BEACON study here, what we see is that when you have low
levels of cytolytic score, you get substantial benefit,
but when you look at the high levels, again, you see that that's a
population that may not be deriving as much benefit.
So I think what do we do with that? We still need to figure out, but I think it's
some really interesting biology that I will admit we don't fully understand
as a field
what that means.
All right, so what's next for BRAF targeting?
So we can say what doesn't work, and we've tried
over the years to double down on it, whether it's with the MEK
inhibitor that was in the initial BEACON study that increased response
rate but not progression-free survival, overall survival compared to the doublet.
But also the idea of can we double back?
These are very MAP kinase addicted tumors.
How about if we add an ERK inhibitor in this setting?
So this is the ARASCA007 study
that was presented by Mike Lee from MD Anderson.
What you can see is in 10 patients that had prior encorafenib and
cetuximab, really no activity. So the therapeutic index
perhaps of the ERK inhibitor is somewhat limiting
given that toxicity.
Pluxerafenib is another paradox breaker that's
been reported, and this is the advantage of being at
the last day of AACR is that you can pull data from earlier
in the meeting. So I'll be sharing some posters here.
But this is some reports that came out, and you can see 14 patients
with BRAFV600E previously treated.
There is some activity here, not a home run, but
certainly hints of some activity perhaps
that may be relevant.
There are degraders that are coming.
This is some pre-clinical data of a degrader, an
EGFR combination, and you can see that the
degrader and EGFR is superior to the encorafenib and
EGFR, at least in this model. But these are areas
I think there's a lot of interest in understanding this class of therapies.
Another area is thinking about combinations and acknowledging that
BRAF is a very epigenetically dysregulated tumor, and
so very high hypermethylation. Near 100% of
tumors would be considered a CIMP high population or
CpG island methylated phenotype high.
So this was
work that's
been presented and now impressed with Haemin Lee from my
lab, where we did an unbiased Cas9 screen
looking for epigenetic regulators
and modulators of BRAF sensitivity and identified
bromodomain as a really key screen.
In the bromodomain inhibitors using the
IBET and the Zenith compounds,
able to show in a number of PDX models that the combination of
the bromodomain inhibitor
is providing benefit and just acknowledging that we then opened an
ETCTN study that just finished enrolling.
So that's a phase 1/2 study through the
NCI led by Sal Alonzo, a physician scientist in my
group,
and so hopefully we'll have some updates to be able to share on that clinical
translation as well.
So where are we? Well, BRAF EGFR is active.
There's a lot of really interesting biology going on that's
resulting in the
adaptive resistance and transcriptomic signatures that we need to
better define. We're fortunate that we have an approval for encorafenib,
cetuximab in combination with FOLFOX and FOLFIRI,
and
the magnitude of benefit is certainly meaningful for the patients.
But we also acknowledge that we don't have great
ideas yet
or at least great signals of what to do afterwards, and so this is a really
huge unmet need. And where I would advocate on behalf of the
BRAF patients, previouslyPeople and
drug development were a bit wary of BRAF population because of
their poor prognosis. But these are patients that, because of the activity
of Breakwater, are in great shape.
These median survival now is equivalent to that of
your non-BRAF population patients.
So this is a really interesting active area
for investigation if there's ideas and agents that could
fit in this space. I didn't touch on it, this was all V600E,
but there certainly is limited options for the non-V600E
populations. It's a bit heterogeneous, but some of the paradox
breakers, the degraders or others may be providing some hints,
but have to stay tuned on that.
All right. So what about KRAS?
So
I'll share a bit of the progress there, and I think a lot
of the hope
in the second half here talking about our KRAS mutated population.
So just a reminder, we're back to that 40 to 50%
population.
G12C is a few percent, but about
12% is G12D, as we'll talk about. So there are larger
groups there.
There's a whole spectrum of different inhibitors.
Here's a mutation specific inhibitors that we'll talk about.
We'll also discuss the pan-KRAS
targeting all of
KRAS, and then pan-RAS inhibitors that now will inhibit
KRAS as well as NRAS and HRAS. And this
is a figure from Ryan Corcoran,
forgot to reference it, apologies.
But
really this idea about tolerability profile
and patient population size are really, I think, important
trade-offs to consider here.
Now, there's a lot of distinct strategies here, both mutant selective
off-state, mutant on off-state, pan-KRAS, as mentioned, the
tricomplex, and the degraders as well.
I won't go into that in great detail here, but of course, there's a number of
wonderful lectures earlier in the conference
that I'm sure you had seen.
Now here, at least according to our best AI
tools of digging through clinicaltrials.gov, is the
current landscape of agents targeting KRAS and
RAS that are in clinic, at least as of a month ago.
And you can see the real spectrum, like 72 agents,
two are approved as we'll go through, and a
number that are actively recruiting.
But certainly G12C leads the pack, but you can see the G12D,
and we'll talk through some of that pan-KRAS and then some of the others here
as well.
So mutant selective inhibitors, let's start there.
Of course, G12C is the poster child for colorectal,
even though it's 3%.
So this is the adagrasib cetuximab combination
response rate 34%, progression-free survival
6.9%, and then received accelerated approval on the base of
this data by the FDA.
Sotorasib panitumumab had the CodeBreaK
300 study published in the New England Journal.
Aaron Fakih is the first author
there, looking at two different doses
but identified the optimal dose of 960 with a median
PFS of 5.6 compared to the standard of care of two, and that
too has been FDA approved.
There are other, what so-called second generation, although I'll acknowledge
how to define generations is always tricky.
But
olomerasib is a second generation G12C inhibitor,
43% response rate's been previously presented at
ASCO last year with a PFS of 7.4 months.
So certainly numerically favorable.
We had some really interesting data from AACR
presented by Kanwal Rahgoff from MD Anderson
using elacestrant
that has very rapid target
engagement and at least preclinical identified that it
can overcome some of the growth factor feedback.
And so you can see some of the EGFR
stimulated western blots down there below.
But I think first, to my knowledge in the field, is that this is really
active as monotherapy. So not an EGFR combination,
but monotherapy at the 600 milligram dose at a
47% response rate
with this agent. So I think encouraging to have an agent, but also encouraging
an interesting biology that may get around this feedback.
But like everything, a little EGFR makes everything better, like a little salt
sprinkled on. And indeed, with an EGFR inhibitor here,
response rate went up to 62%.
So very encouraging data confirmed a response rate of
52%,
and we'll look forward to more updates on that as well.
If we put it across
in a table form, obviously I didn't highlight all of them, but calling
out divurasib, that's numerically providing very high
response rates in combination with cetuximab alone.
Intriguing where you're going from response rates of 30% up to
response rates of 50s, even as high as 60%,
but the PFS has gone from six months to maybe seven
or eight months. So we've really not yet seen a substantial extension
of the PFS despite the fact that these are next
generation, quote unquote, "inhibitors."
These are moving to first line, CodeBreak 301, kind of like
02.
Here you can see those plans and
study sizes. So estimated completions here of '28 and
'29. But the real hope is that just like in Breakwater,
that we'll see someSuperadditivity
perhaps clinically with the combination with cytotoxic therapies and
that some of the benefits we see in second-line may be even augmented
in the first-line settings.
Now, what about D?
So not a whole lot of clinical data, but I'll share,
I think the zolönrasib is one of the first out of the box, and
I don't have the slide, but for those of you that saw the non-small cell lung
cancer data, I think it was around 52% or so
response rate as monotherapy in lung cancer.
So this is a very active agent here.
In pre-clinical models, this is not clinical data, but pre-clinical models and work
that we'd published together with RevMed,
the RAS on G12D selective inhibitor in cetuximab was
generating response rates of the models around
40% or so. And you can see
also other creative approaches, such as combinations with the
636 or duraxonrasib.
The Verastem VS-7375,
this is an agent that came from
Genfleet. This is some of the
data that was presented in poster form at the conference.
And you can see combinations with EGFR inhibitor with this
G12D inhibitor across a number of different
contexts. As highlighting, again, PDAC and lung
cancer, seeing some of that EGFR augmentation as well.
So while prominent in colorectal, some of these feedback mechanisms
may be present.
No colorectal data to share. Here's the lung cancer data,
42% response rate, 52% in
pancreas. That was presented by Genfleet last year.
Insight, again, not a ton of data been presented, but
monotherapy showing some activity
here. So two out of 11 patients with colorectal
cancer
had
activity with the monotherapy. No combination
data released yet, although anticipated.
And then finally, just reminding, there's a lot of interest in the allele-specific
degrader. This is the Astellas
agent. I think they just dosed their first patient in Phase III for lung cancer.
But there's colorectal cohorts looking at this in combination with
EGFR.
So pivoting a bit, what about pan-KRAS and allele-specific
inhibitors?
Starting with the elephant in the room, as we're
celebrating the pancreas successes for duraxonrasib
and the number one question I've gotten this
year at the meeting is like, "That's amazing.
How's it going in colon with duraxonrasib?" We're going to get there,
but it may not be as monotherapy. So
monotherapy response rate about 9%,
and really pivoting not to these monotherapies for
colorectal, but thinking about how do you combine these in thoughtful
ways. Some data, 12 patients treated with pan-RAS and the
G12D inhibitor that's been reported, so 3 out of those
12 with activity. So I think pan-RAS inhibitors remain
to be seen. Pan-KRAS inhibitors are entering clinic.
We don't have any clinical data yet, but just an example of
some agents being developed.
ETX929, again, hot off the press from this year's meeting.
You can see the activity in
monotherapy and then, of course, combination here with EGFR showing
benefit as well.
Now, the key questions in the field is, if we
really need EGFR inhibition, will we be able to
combine that safely with
pan-RAS or
multi-RAS inhibitors? And will that EGFR provide clinical
benefit there? So
we are excited by certainly the G12Cs and the
Ds and the Vs, but colorectal cancer has a long tail.
And half of colorectal
cancer KRAS mutations or RAS mutations broadly are
outside of those big
three ones that we're seeing the most development for allele-specifics.
So just acknowledging that while we're very excited and hope for development of the
allele-specifics, that there's still a fairly large unmet need
with the allele-specific strategies.
Okay. So last few minutes, talk a little bit about some of
the areas where the field is going and thinking about combinations and the biology
there.
So of course, the first is immunotherapy.
KRAS inhibitors have a large body of data, of course, in other
tumor types, but colorectals is no exception to the idea
that RAS inhibitors can modulate the immune
response and environment. This was a nice
summary
from a
poster that was presented at the meeting this year, but just
highlighting all the different things that RAS inhibitors can do and how they may
modulate the microenvironment.
Now, we had some patient data. So this is data from David Hong
from MD Anderson had presented this at the meeting
this year, and this was paired biopsies from the sotorasib
panitumumab, so G12C approved agent, as you recall.
And this was paired biopsies. What they identified is this
induction of a lymphocyte clustering at the tumor stromal interface.
So it wasn't that the immune cells were swarming throughout the tumor, but they
were definitely coming into the tumor microenvironment,
and the RNAseq evidence of immune activation was seen on these paired
biopsies. So again, 10 patients, but really deep
translational insights, I think nicely
done.There is a study that
Christine Parsigian from MD Anderson is leading as part of our Stand Up
to Cancer collaboration with MGH and Ryan Corcoran looking at
adagrasib, cetuximab, and cemiplimab.
And so this is
ongoing, and hopefully be able to share some data to ask the question,
is there actually a benefit with a PD-1
combination in this setting? But fortunately, have been able to
safely administer this
combination. Now, there's other avenues
here. Certainly, the PROTACs are active
spaces,
and there is at least theoretical reasons that the PROTACs,
because they're degrading and presenting some of these neoantigens, may
actually improve immune response.
So this was, again, an AACR poster
here, and what we saw in the mouse studies, looking at the
dark blue and the orange, is that the PROTAC plus
PD-1, at least in this model, was showing improved rates of
CRs comparing to a pan-RAS inhibitor and PD-1.
So
early data, but at least,
will PROTACs and PD-1s be good
partners?
So I mentioned certainly the concepts of innate resistance here, and I will
share a few things.
Alex Sorkin from my lab had presented
some co-clinical trials. So here
are 140 different PDX models that were either RAS wild type
treated with EGFR G12C, with G12C
EGFR or BRAF with
BRAF and EGFR. So by doing this, you get a really
clean signals to be able to look at what
are some of the mechanisms and predictors of innate resistance.
And so by doing this, he was able to really cleanly
tease out at least the tumor intrinsic.
Remember, these are PDXes, so the tumor intrinsics are real strengths
here,
and identified that models with the PI3 kinase and the aptide
signaling had reduced response to these inhibitors
at baseline. And this led to a number of
opportunities then to think about how do you follow up on that.
And I just wanted to highlight a few.
In the interest of time, I won't go through all of them, but there are some
interesting leads here. So the idea to say, well, how do you combine with a
PI3 kinase inhibitor, for example?
Now we know the limitations of certainly AKT inhibitors
there, but I think there are some really intriguing opportunities.
The
breakers of the RAS PI3 kinase, an example is
the BridgeBio 10203. So the idea, of
course, is that normally PI3 kinase, when it's
activated through
upstream RTKs, will signal down through AKT.
RAS, when it's mutated, will activate
AKT pathway as well, and it does that by binding
P110 alpha.
The idea is that by having a covalent inhibitor,
there's a cysteine 242 on the P110 alpha
that they developed an inhibitor to that
prevents the binding of the mutated RAS.
And importantly, it preserves the PI3 kinase catalytic
function. So you're not inhibiting the catalytic function of
PI3 kinase, just preventing the activation of it by RAS.
And so the idea is you don't get that glucose
homeostasis dysregulation. You don't get that hyperglycemia and
the other toxicities that accompany it.
So just preclinical data at this point, but looking at this ability to
really understand how can you
combine pan KRAS, for example, with the breaker,
and again, in a number of settings here, you can see improvements
in outcomes. So stay tuned in this area, but hopefully a better
therapeutic window. What about YAP/TEAD?
This is something well-recognized in the field already.
It was reported out in "Nature,"
now a year and a half ago or so.
But I just wanted to call out again a poster from this year.
Amgen did a really nice unbiased screen and said,
"What are the modulators of resistance to a
pan-KRAS inhibitor?" And identified in that setting,
as you can see, a number of really
real focus that just
came out of the YAP/TEAD signaling pathway.
So the Hippo pathway is a key one.
And just highlighting this is work from Olu Coker, from a graduate
student in my lab who has
a paper working his way through the system, looking at patient-derived
xenografts that are able to confirm that from patients that have been treated with
these inhibitors. And indeed, just confirming again with a pan-TEAD
inhibitor, you can take these resistant PDX models from patients
progressing on EGFR, KRAS, and show
activity.
Back to the same
paper from David Hong from MD Anderson that I mentioned earlier.
They also looked at these paired biopsies and the sotorasib panitumumab.
And again, what you can see is, yes, there's a number of other interesting
pathways such as RTKs coming up, but the
universal finding here, nearly universal, was that YAP
signaling was indeed up. And so I think really,
albeit a small number of patients, a really
clear signaling
relevance in our patients.
So what about adaptive resistance?
So
this is recognizing, of course, that cellular plasticity is driving a subset
of resistance. This is a paper that came out
just from Owen Samson's group not that long ago, but it took
a syngeneic model treated with a G12D inhibitor
and actually identified a population that expanded out of a MAP
kinase offBut really went activated.
And so this idea, if you can really hit this high,
this WNT
signaling has appeared as a mechanism of
defining a population's resistance.
So Oscar Villarreal, a graduate student,
physician, scientist in my lab, did some bar
coding to track some of this and identified that
the ASCL2 index
really went up after these MAP kinase
pathway inhibitors, and that this ASCL2 in
our hands
was the better marker, but also this population's been defined as an
LGR5 one. So we're all calling these slightly
different terms, but when you actually look at all the
different scores that have been defined here,
this recognition that this WNT proliferative state
signature, cancer stem cell signature with WNT
activation is all part of a very similar biology.
And so this really aligns with that population.
And when you go in and you actually deplete, you can do a diphtheria toxin
experiment to deplete the cells that express
ASCL2,
you can eliminate those persister cells after treatment.
So I think this number of
different groups really identifying a similar biology here.
This is Roar Bhatul
publication recently looking at LGR5, so you remember that was
co-expressed with ASCL2 and just showing here again, diphtheria
toxin to the LGR5, you can improve survival compared with
RAS inhibition alone.
So in conclusion,
we're making advances.
We've made good progress with G12C.
We're anticipating tolerability of the G12D inhibitors in
combination with EGFR, but it's still early days and the clinical data will be
coming.
Pan RAS, in contrast, we have to really
rethink that a little bit. At least
the first foray, that may not be the solution for colorectal, but
there's lots of creative solutions here to think through.
And then the big question is, are pan KRASs going to be more
like the allele specific toxicity profiles?
Are they going to be more like the pan RAS?
And the big question is, do you need
EGFR combinations there, and then can you tolerate it?
So novel combinations and development based on improved understanding of the
biology, but I'm really excited, as you
heard, and really to see some of the translational insights
from patients. And I think that really gives us faith that some of these
signals we're seeing pre-clinically are real, and I would just encourage us as a
field to continue to learn as much as we can from the patients to help guide
which of these areas are the priority. So I'll end there.
I just think I shared a lot of our group's
work along the way where it was relevant and just want to thank them and the number
of wonderful collaborators in and outside of the institution.
So thank you so much for your
attention.
We have the last presentation, then we will open for questions from
the audience and from those who are online.
So I will complete reviewing a few of the emerging
targets for MSS metastatic colorectal
cancer.
And we working at earlier stage
most of the cases than we are with RAF and RAS, but
certainly we have already enough data to show that colorectal cancer
is going to be very much like lung cancer, breast cancer,
where you're going to have a lot of subdivisions of patients being treated in a
very
personalized way.
Perhaps the best target with the data that is
already actionable at this point is HER2.
It's been a decade since the Italian group showed that the combination of
the tyrosine kinase inhibitor lapatinib with trastuzumab
was effective with a relatively modest but significant
response rate for patients who were already heavily pretreated but
had heavy expressions of HER2.
Certainly not in the same range that you would expect, for example, with breast
cancer in the same situation, but something that has been used
in clinical practice. Lapatinib, as some of you may
know, it's not a
necessarily easy medication to be used.
And more recently, we have data with the new tyrosine kinase
inhibitor tucatinib with trastuzumab, which show not
only significant response rate, but as of
importance in this relatively small trial, show a
significant improvement in the median overall survival expected,
reaching for those patients close to two years, which is a significant
improvement over we had before, besides a very
significant response rate, which was about 10% higher than
we had with lapatinib and trastuzumab.
Now, tucatinib and trastuzumab generate so much enthusiasm, and now we
have a phase three trial comparing the
combination of tucatinib, trastuzumab in
FOLFOX versus FOLFOX and bevacizumab
or cetuximab, so the standard of care.
We do not have yet
the result of this trial, but it's eagerly awaited and may actually
change the way we treat in first line patients with
HER2 overexpression.
When we talk about HER2, now it's
impossible not to mention the ADC trastuzumab
deruxtecan.
It has shown significant clinical activity in patients with
colorectal cancer with heavy expression of HER2.
This is the DestinyCRC-02 trial in
which two different doses of trastuzumab deruxtecan
were applied to patients who were heavily pre-treated with colorectal cancer.
And you see the response rates were excellent, between 30% and 40%,
independent of the dose that was being used, with overall
survivals that were over a year, which is very good, and in the
best case, reaching 20 months.
Concerning that those patients were heavily pre-treated, of course, this was
something of great interest. We have had some
significant toxicity with the compound.
We are used to that already with the use that we have had in lung and breast
cancer. So nothing necessarily new, but something to be taken in
consideration. So when we talk about the HER2 as a target,
we began with trastuzumab lapatinib with response rates around
30%. It has gone up with trastuzumab tucatinib to
38%. We're waiting to see what's going to be the response rate
here when this combination is added to a conventional chemotherapy
regimen. And as Dr. Kopetz
said, even 70 years later, it seems that we cannot escape 5-FU.
It continues to add to the treatments that we use.
And finally, we have the trastuzumab deruxtecan,
which uses, of course, a TOP1 inhibitor
as the payload with response rates
approaching 45%, close to 50%. Certainly
lower than what we see with breast cancer, but very much
significant for the treatment of patients with colorectal cancer and the first-line
treatment,
first-line trial with trastuzumab deruxtecan is ongoing at this point.
There's also the idea of using a multi-target TKI,
since some TKIs have been successful in the past.
Zanza is a multi-target TKI that
targets VEGF-R, MET, and TIG. And the idea here was
to use this in combination with
immunotherapy. So Zanza plus Atezo was a
trial that was conducted and presented recently, the STELLAR-303.
Patients were randomized to receive Zanza plus
atezolizumab versus regorafenib in third
line or further.
Patients were already heavily pre-treated, regorafenib being a
tyrosine kinase inhibitor that's approved in this situation.
And when we look at the results, the response rate was not much
improved. However, there was a statistically significant improvement in the
overall survival
that went from 9.4 to 10.9 months, so about one and a half
months gain with the combination.
Certainly less than we would want, but it was statistically
significant.
The other area that's being investigated are the bispecific
antibodies. Perhaps the one that's further along in
the development and in the research is amivantamab.
Amivantamab is approved for the treatment of lung cancer.
And here the idea was to take those patients who have been already
treated with
cetuximab or panitumumab and try to use as
a rescue. And you can see that for those
patients who had been exposed to anti-EGFR and had a
relatively long period of rest in between the
exposure to the re-exposure with
amivantamab, the progression-free survival and overall survival was
quite interesting. So for those patients with more than six months of
interval between the original treatment and then amivantamab,
you had about a very long
interval and a median overall survival of 16 months.
As a rescue, that's pretty significant.
Now, there is the idea of moving this forward.
Instead of using cetuximab or panitumumab, using the
bispecific antibody up front, so amivantamab
subcutaneously with chemotherapy versus cetuximab
with chemotherapy for patients with left-sided tumors.
The idea here is to see if you can block the development of resistance and
improve progression-free survival and perhaps overall survival for those patients
being treated with the bispecific antibody. It remains to be seen.
It's an ongoing trial. Now, there are other
bispecific antibodies being developed.
There's a TGF beta 2 with PD-1
inhibitor for solid tumors.
This TGF beta signaling is important, and the idea
is to block those two together with the Zynside agent.
The results are very preliminary, but we have up to 20%
response rates with the antibody as a single
agent.
Development continues. Now, of note, and I would like to point here, it
seems that those patients who have higher expression of PD-L1 had higher
response rate than those patients who had lower, showing that at least part of
the response is coming certainly from the PD-1
inhibition. Antibody-drug conjugates, I had mentioned to you
already trastuzumab deruxtecan, which is very important and
it's commercially available, but there are others.
There's the PrismTCT,
which was one of the lead investigators, Dr.
Kopetz, maybe he can comment to that later to us, but it's
a CCAM directed antibody with an interesting
payload. And the result was also
interesting with confirmed
response rate of 20% for patients who have been heavily pre-treated
before. So it's another way, another different target
that might become more useful in the near future.
Now, there is the ABBV-400, which is an anti-MET
antibody with topoisomerase I payload, novel
payload. The idea here is to use the c-MET as an
anchor to try todeliver higher doses of the
Topo1 inhibitor intracellularly, and the response rates were also very
interesting with those patients with higher expression of cMET having
up to 37% response rate with the monoclonal
antibody. It was decided that the antibody should
be moved forward, and the phase three trial in first line is also
being developed at this point.
There's the idea of the bispecific ADCs, something new.
You not only use a bispecific antibody, but you conjugate that with a
payload as well. It's one of the novel ways of trying to
use these new technologies, and certainly there is a long list
of those agents being tried and experimented in colorectal cancer.
At this point, we do not have solid data or evidence to present to you,
but it's something that would pay close attention because I think in the next few
months, we'll be seeing a lot of results of those trials coming forward.
Now it remains to be seen if the efficacy will improve, but also
if the toxicity will be relevant or not
for those patients. And then there's the idea of making those
patients more responsive to immunotherapy.
Why should only patients with microsatellite instability
respond to immunotherapy? There has to be a way for us to open
the response for those patients who are stable as well.
And there is a combination, bot bal, bot nacilimab is a
novel CTL4 inhibitor with
enhanced Fc fraction. Bot
stilimab is anti-PD1, a more
conventional anti-PD1. It's the idea that with
bot, you would have enhanced T-cell priming and activation
with more activation of APCs and myeloid cells and
reduce regulatory T-cells, making those patients where
previously
had tumors that were cold become hot and be treated
more effectively. In the phase one trial that was conducted in
colorectal cancer with heavily pretreated tumors, we did
have 20% of the
patients with
response rates that lasted for about
16 months. So showing at least that you can have
response rates in patients who are stable using immunotherapy.
However, this, of course, was very initial and the development of the
medication continues. At this point, it's important to
note that the medication seems to be more effective for
patients who have tumors that are
located outside of the liver. Patients with liver metastasis tend to respond
less. This was a phase two trial which used a standard of
care comparator with trifluridine or Lonsurf
and had different doses of bot and bal being investigated.
The response rates were very good, as I said, close to 20% in the
best-case scenarios. This is very much superior to
what you have with TAS-102 or trifluridine and
regorafenib.
Now, the toxicity is significant as you would expect,
especially for an anti-CTL4 that's enhanced.
There is enhanced toxicity as well in this case here.
That's something that we medical oncologists are used to deal with, so
it's certainly manageable, but it's something that has to
be taken into consideration because you do have the immune-related
toxicities that you would expect from this agent.
And there is a randomized phase three trial for patients with
stable
disease
MSS. It's the BATMAN trial where patients who have
been heavily pretreated receive either the bot/bal or best supportive
care. The idea is to see if in a large patient population, you
would still have the same response rate and duration of response that was seen in
the phase one trial, because that certainly would be very important for management
of those patients, particularly those that have been already treated
without the available treatment options at this point.
There's some other promising agents that are starting to be
evaluated at this point.
One very interesting idea is to try to
induce
more mutations in the tumor. This is a PMS2
inhibitor, the NP1867. The idea is when you
give this to the patient, you induce an instability in the tumor
and make the tumor generate new antigens and hopefully activate the
immune system more effectively than you would otherwise.
So it's a novel and very, I think, very
curious and interesting way of trying to bypass the normal resistance to
immunotherapy that you have with these stable patients.
Now it remains to be seen if it will work on day to day, but at
least in mice, it seems to be an effective way of reversing the
resistance. Then we have a whole list of other agents.
Of course, we wouldn't have enough time to talk deeply about any of
them, but I think the anti-CCR8
antibodies are a very interesting way of moving forward.
And the GCC CAR T-cells also, I think, are
strategies that could generate interesting results in the future.
So I think that we have a lot coming.
I think that the group of patients with colorectal cancer will be further and
further divided in small subgroups that will be treated in a
very different and very specific ways, and perhaps that's the way that we can
move forward in the treatment of this disease.
So I think the take home messages at this point, there
has been precision progress in HER2 and RAS and RAF,
of course, as you have seen by Dr. Kopetz presentations.
ADCs seems to be increasingly important, and I just saw
today a presentation that listed about 540
different ADCs being investigated at this time.
Certainly, a lot of them are targeting colorectal cancer, and we should be seeing
new results and new trials in the near future.
We have to try to bridge MSS to immunotherapy and
Innovative ways such as inducing new antigens or
perhaps improving the anti-CTL4,
anti-PD1s are sensible ways to move forward.
And I think there is no way of moving away from the idea that you're going to have
to have more and more personalization and focus on biomarkers and
combinations as the best way to move forward
in this field. With that, I would like to finish and
invite you to ask questions. Thank you.
Please go ahead.
Okay. Norbert Klotz from BI. Thanks to both speakers.
Really nice presentations, and thanks for incorporating the latest
highlights from this meeting. A question maybe to both of
you, combination partners for BRAF and
KRAS inhibitors. You mentioned cetuximab.
As we have seen some of the bispecific EGFR
inhibitors are antibodies, what are your thoughts on the
prospects for combining those?
Yeah, it's a great question, and intriguing because we have
bispecifics such as amivantamab that we heard about
that target MET. We see MET amplified as a genomic
resistance mechanism, and of course, we can imagine that MET is also
being activated
through non-genomic signaling mechanisms. So that's intriguing.
The bispecific with the LGR5, the PIDO that
Dr. Hofe mentioned, some interesting potential
there because as we're showing, these
LGR5 populations can represent some of the
resistant clones. Now,
and so thinking about
whether or not that is playing a role.
There's always a question of how much of that is signaling and
driving versus a marker of a resistant state.
So that's part of the areas about thinking about it as an
antibody versus, for example, ADCs that may just
be using that to drive that. So actually, I'm
intrigued a little bit about some of these ways to think about how can we use
ADCs as partners where the ADCs are there to really
constrain the resistance pathways that may be available.
Thank you.
Scott, we have a question, actually two questions from the
online viewers. One of them is that if you could comment on the
PFS2 post-break water.
Yeah, it's a great question. We don't have that data
formally yet.
But the absence of data, that allows me to just to
share experience-
Give us what you want
... right?
But yeah, it is interesting that in our
prior expectations, if we look at historic data around what
second-line, third-line PFS is for BRAF
V600E patients pre-BRAF
targeting, it was two months, two months, two months.
Meaning the majority of patients were just progressing right away in
second, third line. That's not the pattern that we see after
post-break water, that a number of these patients, the
resistant tumors are not nearly as aggressive
uniformly. Now, there's certainly plenty that do.
But there is a sense that
the resistant tumors post-break water have a more
indolent biology that may match a more traditional
non-BRAF population for reasons that I don't think we fully
understand there. But I think that the sense is that
PFS2 may be very close to what we'd expect out of a
second-line broader population.
Just before your question, a follow-up question here is what is
your second line post-break water?
Boy, yeah.
So it is a difficult question. What
I'm doing in practice is
switching to the alternate cytotoxic agent, and again, getting
more mileage than you'd expect historically out of that.
And then there's some intriguing early data about
rechallenge strategies, and so the idea if you're
stepping away from BRAF targeting, people then come back to it again following
the rechallenge data that's
been present for many years for EGFR in a RAS/RAF wild type, for
example. I don't know, but we are anecdotally
seeing activity in those settings.
Thank you for organizing this session. A question about preSENTCT.
The results were promising, but there was a very high rate of
neutropenia that you don't necessarily observe with other
exotic ADCs, and also a lack of correlation with
CCND5 expression. And in ADCs, that's often taken
to mean that you have a significant activity from free
payload.
So I'm wondering what's your take on that?
Yeah. To share mine-
It's your trial.
Yeah. All right. So,
the preSENTCT, I think the one
finding is that the CCND5 expression was
sufficiently high across the board that
you didn't see a ton of difference between that.
And I think this is a trend that we're starting to see broadly in
ADC. There's not always as strong a correlation with expression as
we may have thought a year or two or three ago.
And I think we're seeing the same thing with the ABV400, for example, where
even though it's a MET targeting going to a MET-agnostic
population for next developmentsteps in combination of
nivisimumab.
But in the app, the response rate was higher for
those who had a higher expression of CMET.
True. Yeah.
So it's not only the payload there.
There is some-
There is some correlation there. I think it's true.
The drug was, to your point about the
neutropenia, I think that was really optimized, and I think the
team worked hard to find just the right dose that was
sustainable, but where you could get that.
So I think we do see with that agent, and along with many others, that there's a
much narrower therapeutic window than maybe we thought five-plus years
ago for ADCs, and that
trying to
get the dosing just right is really critical and helps unlock some of that
activity that we've seen.
Well, and there's no question that the payload gets released as well because,
for example, trastuzumab deruxtecan, we have alopecia,
which is something that bothers a lot of the
patients as well. So it's happening because the payload is
being released. Exetecan is getting to the circulation as well.
And it may actually be helping the result of the drug by
being released.
There's a question here that I'm not quite sure you're going to be able to
answer. But
Scott, they ask if you tested those agents on
wound healing in fibroblasts, if you know the
toxicity profile on fibroblasts.
Yeah.
Good question. And I don't know. I think it is fair to say
that
in the
PDX models, I can say that where you do
have kind of fibroblasts, albeit they're mirroring fibroblasts, that
you don't see a ton of change in those fibroblasts.
The tumors will respond, and there's still kind of
healthy-looking fibroblasts that remain in the tumor there.
But the real question about wound healing, I think we haven't seen signals of wound
healing in the clinic with these, but a
lot of the ones in the clinic have been the allele-specific ones where we may not
expect it.
Yeah. We had a patient that had a lesion removed after doing
the breakwater, and the lesion had
turned negative on the PET, and when it was removed, there was
only cicatricial tissue in there.
So I guess fibroblasts are working in there, but-
Yeah
... the tumor is gone.
Matt Maxwell. I'm a postdoc at Tempus.
I was just curious your feelings on trial
development in the adjuvant setting.
Since cetuximab failed quite a while ago, it seems like there hasn't been
as much interest in the adjuvant setting.
Do you think that these targeted agents that could be paired with
cetuximab or amivantamab,
is there appetite for that in ctDNA
positive selected patients?
It's a great question, and I'd say that
there's attempts to, for example, to go and do a BRAF adjuvant kind
of all-comer, and that just
sample size and the screening kind of collapsed under its own weight,
for lack of a better phrasing there.
So there really has been a push, as you mentioned there, to really think about
ctDNA to help define a population of benefit.
There was a nice, Frank Tennegopp had a
paper
that looked at the NO147 study. So this was an
older adjuvant cetux study but went back with a lens of
ctDNA to see if we could define a responding
population. And it turned out that the ctDNA patients did not
do well with the cetuximab, even a little sense that maybe they did worse.
Again,
retrospective caveats. And so that kind of, I think, put a little bit of
a damper, yet again, on the idea that we should be doing
EGFR
targeting in a RAS/RAF wild type for adjuvant.
But the beauty of these ctDNA studies are if we really wanted to
look in a really well-defined post-FOLFOX patient
to see if targeted therapies are clearing ctDNA,
it's easy to do quick 20-patient
studies to look. Do you clear ctDNA or not?
You don't clear a proportion of patients with ctDNA, move on
because your
success rate there is low. But the opportunities are that now we can
start to do these "Phase 2 adjuvant" or really
better-defined MRD studies in the future.
So I'm hopeful in this space, just maybe not with EGFR.
Great, thanks.
Why do you think the PENN-RAS is not panning out to us?
Well, I think it's just the same
trends that we've seen before in that
even with a kind of optimal
dosing that's at the maximum tolerated
dose,
we're not getting sufficient pathway inhibition because of that
EGFR reactivation. And so we just aren't able to push up
high enough in the doses that would be needed to really optimally
suppress the pathway.
I think we answered all the questions that were here.
Any more questions from the audience?
If not, I want to thank you all for being with us on the Wednesday session, and
thank you, Scott, very much for your help. Thank you.
Thank you.